remember this tongue map you probably
haven't seen it since your elementary
school days but it's been around for
decades it divides your tongue into
distinct sections that are responsible
for interpreting sweet sour bitter and
salty tastes it's just wrong and it's
doing a disservice to really the whole
population for disseminating this
incorrect information so why have
generations of students been taught this
map and what else are we getting wrong
about the science of taste to find out
we talked to dr. Robert mark goal ski
from the Monell chemical senses Center
we've all seen this famous map it's from
about a century ago of the tongue
divided it's a different taste like
bitter and sweet turns out that is very
much wrong can you walk us through why
that is not the case that our our tongue
is divided into these neat sections of
different tastes the taste map was
originated by a German researcher and he
came up with his taste map based on
psychological studies of human subjects
for their sensitivity of all different
types of taste qualities sweet sour
salty bitter and what he found was that
the sensitivity was not even throughout
the tone there was least sensitivity at
the very middle of the tongue and most
sensitivity right around the edges and
he also found relatively small
differences for different taste
qualities more sweet sensitivity towards
the front more bitter sensitivity
towards the back but this has been
converted down the years into a more
extreme version of the taste map that
says sweet is at the front of the
diamond and that's where it is bitter is
at the back salty and sour at the sides
and that is totally incorrect okay so
that's wrong we have taste buds doing
all sorts of things all over the tongue
what exactly are those taste buds doing
walk us through how the taste buds
actually produce what we experience as
taste at the front of your tongue you
find a lot of taste buds in bump like
structures and each of those taste buds
as 50 to 100 specialized taste receptor
cells that will respond to different
taste qualities
some they respond to sweet some to sour
others to salty and others to bitter and
most would add to it amino acid taste
mami and in some cases it looks like
they respond to multiple types of taste
qualities in other cases they seem to be
very narrowly defined when you are
tasting things you perhaps start
salivating is this in any way signalling
to your stomach that okay this is
happening this is tasting good prepare
for food I'm not gonna spit this out
this is coming your way
yes that's exactly right so the taste
system even though we take it for
granted serves a number of important
factors in our life the most significant
one is a decision point is this good for
me will I allow it into my body with the
expectation that it will be nutritious
and a good food source for me or is it
potentially poisonous might it be toxic
what happens though when our taste buds
get injured does a body have a really
rapid response in bringing them them
back operationally in general the taste
system is pretty robust and your taste
cells may have kind of a lifetime
between one week two weeks maybe three
weeks and then they will regenerate
rarely you can lose function to those
two taste buds because of damage to a
branch of the nerve and that is normally
connecting to that taste bud so on the
opposite end of the spectrum we have
super tasters I personally am NOT a
super taster unfortunately but what is
going on in the bodies of these folks
who have become super tasters the super
taster phenotype is an observation where
people are incredibly sensitive to all
types of taste qualities and its most
obvious with bitter compounds the
flipside are they're not exactly non
tasters but they're very insensitive and
they can hardly detect at all these
chemical compounds that you'll find in
broccoli Brussels sprouts and so maybe
their favorite vegetable is broccoli or
Brussels sprouts because they're tasting
other compounds and not these particular
bitter compounds that their super taster
brethren are more sensitive to yeah if
I'm bitter particularly interesting
because it seems like something you
might be able to adapt to like me
personally I absolutely didn't start
drinking beer until I was 21 obviously
and I didn't really like it at first
it's too bitter but now that I'm 35 I
like it very much
is there a way actually for the the
human body to adapt more to like a
tastes like bitter younger children tend
to be very sensitive to bitter more than
an adult it's not genetics but maybe
it's developmental or epigenetic so that
an earlier stage we're more sensitive to
crave sweet and fat but with time we can
learn that hey that bitter stuff is not
really bad and I can associate it with a
very positive effect for example those
that like beer for the alcohol buzz or
those that like caffeine either from
coffee or tea or other beverages can
associate the bitterness with a pleasant
psychological activity a little bit of
Pleasant buzz from the alcohol a little
bit of Pleasant buzz always we also
wanted to talk about cilantro perhaps
the most divisive herb on the planet
some people hate it some people think it
tastes great some people think it tastes
like soap I'm not one of those luckily
what's going on with cilantro do we
understand the mechanisms as to why some
people hate it and some people don't
again it gets back into your genes some
people will have the genetic type where
cilantro has a wonderful flavor and if
you don't have that particular receptor
or that version of the receptor you'll
have a different receptor that responds
to it and just detects it as something
kind of nasty unpleasant so there's a
really interesting evolutionary story
here right you have taste both for
detecting bad things in our environment
you don't want to eat a plant that's
poisonous if you can taste bitter
compounds you're more likely to avoid
that plant and so survive but the other
side of this is also your body being
able to anticipate certain foods and
digest them better would theoretically
give you an evolutionary and
right that's exactly right so you're
gonna have both positive and negative
selection that's really interesting it
kind of makes me think about other
creatures out in the world how they're
tasting things that are going into their
bodies so would say a carnivore have
fewer sweet receptors or really any at
all because it just hasn't needed those
throughout its evolutionary history
that's exactly right in and the cat is a
very interesting example of that cats
they live off a protein in their diet
and they generally don't eat plants and
so they don't really need to be able to
detect a sweet plant a ripe fruit they
just need to be able to find the best
source of protein cats actually cannot
taste sweet and so if you give a cat
vanilla ice cream and your cat likes it
the reason they like it doesn't have to
do with the sugar they presumably like
it because of the fat or maybe the amino
acid umami component of it so if we can
understand taste better is there a way
that we might be able to improve human
health when it comes to eating there's
kind of a disconnect between the way we
evolved under conditions where it was
hard to find ripe fruit or nutritive
sources to the current day where you can
just go to a grocery store and you can
buy up as much of whatever you want and
so our tendency is to overeat and
especially to overeat sugar and other a
calorie rich foods so there are studies
ongoing right now at 1:00 L to see if we
can also change people's setpoint their
preference for sweet from a level where
it would be high sugar high calories to
a level where it would be moderate
levels of calories and that could serve
as a diet aid and we would hope reduce
the incidence of obesity and thereby
reduce the incidence of diabetes thanks
for being with us today and if you
excuse me I'm gonna go eat a lot of food
my pleasure and enjoy your lunch
you